un amendement en ce sens du mot termina
parole est à monsieur alain suguenot
verse
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'éducation nationale veut d'emblée me
lis depuis quelques jours le président
de république à beaujeu d'indiquer que
les réformes promises seront mises en
oeuvre mais quelle réforme la demi
réformes votées avec le 49-3 qui ne
changera rien au quotidien des français
une loi macro qui a fait pschitt
une réforme constitutionnelle qui a fait
splatch les noëls khumri qui va faire
plouf et des cartes de mesures et que
dire de l'école balla mélissa semaine
dernière vous avez tenu en grande pompe
les journées de la refondation
rassemblement très médiatique hôtel
eurent de bilan et de satisfecit
gouvernementales alors que les
différends avec les enseignants les
parents d'élèves et les élus ne cessent
de se multiplier
je pars mais plus d'échecs des rythmes
scolaires souliers par un rapport
d'inspection générale finalisé depuis
plus d'un an mais toujours non publiée
qui semble s'être perdu en chemin il est
vrai que ce rapport est inquisitoire sur
l'efficacité pédagogique de cette
réforme et bien sûr sur le coût que
représente pour les collectivités les
familles et la fatigue des élèves
vous connaissez le trouble que cause
également la réforme des collèges il est
vrai que pour beaucoup vos réformes sont
destructrices
vous n'avez de cesse madame la ministre
de vous battre contre tout ce qui
représente l'éducation et l'enseignement
traditionnel comme si vous souhaitiez un
monde sans mérite ni autorité
l'abbé ministre les journées la
refondation de trompe personne
nous avons bien compris qu'il s'agissait
d'un plan de communication ces journées
ont surtout été évité un certain nombre
de sujets structurelle qui est pourtant
urgent d'aborder comme le positionnement
central de l'enseignant dans les écoles
la réforme d'un ministère complètement
coupée des réalités et la montée en
puissance inquiétant du communautarisme
ma question est donc simple madame la
ministre quand allez vous enfin aborder
ces vrais sujets je crois que la seule
augmentation de 800 euros nos
instituteurs pourtant mérité ne
suffisent pas en effet à revaloriser
l'école et rassurer ceux qui croyaient
que l'école devait être une priorité et
que vous ne cessez de décevoir si la
parole quand madame najat
vallaud-belkacem mini duel d'occasion
nationale l'enseignement supérieur et de
la recherche
merci monsieur le président
ns et messieurs les députés monsieur le
député alain suguenot merci pour votre
question que j'ai écouté avec la plus
grande attention donc j'en retiens
j'en retiens que vous considérez comme
juste et méritée l'augmentation du
salaire des professeurs d'école mais que
vous nous reprocher de l'avoir réalisé
j'en retiens que vous estimez que ces
dernières années l'école française a été
dévalorisée mais que dans un fâcheux
troubles amnésiques
vous oubliez que c'est d'avoir détruit
80 mille postes dans l'éducation
nationale sans compter la formation des
enseignants est d'avoir préféré le curé
à l'instituteur pour transmettre les
valeurs aux élèves qu'il a dévalorisé
j'en retiens j'en retiens que vous aimez
l'excellence à voir sortir du système
scolaire sans qualification un élève sur
quatre monsieur martin
j'en retiens que vous aimez le mérite
mais rien ne vous choque avoir le
déterminisme social l'emporter 100 fois
plus que le véritable mérite dans notre
école actuelle j'en retiens cher
monsieur le député suguenot que la
fatigue des enfants désormais scolarisés
sur cinq jours au lieu de quatre vous
aimez mais que lorsqu'on les pressurer
sur quatre journées avec des
dégradations de résultats scolaires
qu'on connaissait ça ça ne vous faisait
ni chaud ni froid
bref monsieur le député suguenot j'en
retiens que votre raisonnement s'il faut
l'appeler ainsi manque cruellement de
cohérence de lucidité et de bonne foi et
j'en suis sincèrement désolé